today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to be to the beach
in Los Angeles great block pizza get
that today's episode is brought to you
by better help.com do you need help damn
right you do better help calm is a place
where you can get mental mental well you
can get mentally well over your phone or
tablet it's a great place to start
therapy if you never thought about
therapy if maybe you talked to somebody
or you you um you might use a Ouija
board or do a uh some people do a
crystal ball and then just wait to see
if anything happens but if you're tired
of those old-school methods then you can
try better help calm it's professional
and affordable counseling I go to
counselors you know III need help
I'm the first one dude somebody offering
help boy I wish I had four hands cuz I
put them all in the air over here help
over here
better help calm has four communication
modes you can text chat phone and video
with an actual therapist that can really
help you I've tried out better help and
I enjoy it better help can let you start
communicating with a therapist in less
than 24 hours it's available worldwide
sign up at better help.com slash Theo
today that's better help calm slash Theo
how we doing you snazzy little
princesses and petunias huh you ready to
test drive your own heartbeat mmm-hmm
are you ready to smile like a like a
walrus on Molly the ocean is open baby
get in
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that-that-that's that that that that
that that that that that that that that
that that that that that's that shiny
sand who hitting us with a little back
in black that's back in black by tiny
sand who and the you know tiny sand who
is oh well what is it
tiny sand who is ovah is a it's a man or
something or it's a it's a being it's a
creature I don't know what it is but it
it has an email and once in a blue moon
it sends an email with the music with a
music attached to it and it just says
hey here's that hitter and that's tiny
sand - and he's been doing that since we
started this podcast and he might be I
don't know what tiny saying who could be
it could be like huh you know a man it
could be somebody that lives in the if I
think about it it seems like you know
maybe a little like a little baby otter
like a baby otter that sometimes you
know has been underwater just making
music I'm just just nibbling on the uh
you know nibbling on the hard parts of
his own tongue and just just feeling the
[ __ ] lavender just the lavender just
run through his own blood stream and
that's tiny sand too and and I feel like
that otter every now and then it comes
to the top of the water and it just
spits out into the air a musical sound
that fills us up and that's tiny sand
whoo and he does that for us and that is
back in black that's his own cover
written just for you and for me thank
you guys for being here with me today it
is it's a good day it has to be it has
to because it's the only one we have
right now you know yeah I mean you could
wait till tomorrow but if you want today
can probably be good so just if today's
starting off for you and a shitty bro
give it another chance
give gift today another chance maybe
y'all got off on a bad foot you think
about that because you know that today
only hat is a one-legged deal you know
and today only hat it has one foot so
that foot can someone be good and
sometimes be bad so if that's the case
just give it a chance give it a chance
let it take another step in your life
and see if that next step is aw is on
the good it lands as a good foot you
know because we have it because you know
sometimes it's like oh I'm having a bad
day well then reintroduce yourself to
the day reacquaint yourself let the day
reach you guys reconsider each other
instead of sitting there all day like
today and she knew today okay know what
we was out of Philadelphia Cream Cheese
and I can't even you know we didn't have
no uh you know caramel topping last
night Berta vanilla ice cream scoops
today since no today didn't start off
well today is a one-legged deal and it
started off on that you know it landed
with that bad imprint into your into
your sandbox
so y'all started off on a bad foot well
let today jump again in your life make
an agreement with today if it's not
going well say hey hey today I'm do and
I want to see if maybe we could do this
differently and let the day reintroduce
itself and you guys give each other
another chance you got to give things
second chances sometimes it's hard
people give you second chances and
sometimes you got to give other people
second chances good to be here thank you
guys for joining me I uh
man I got back from Charlotte I had a
blast in Charlotte we had oh man so many
people came out I want to apologize for
the Late Show on Sat
today they had some people in the they
had some people I think that was on
uppers you know they was probably on I
don't know what the heck they were on
Menino repeated doses of liquor
maybe gunpowder
you know harsh harsh cinnamon one of
them could have been on maybe somebody
maybe they had it some apple pie and it
was just so tart that they just showed
up and we're just complete I asked holes
at the show but finally they tossed
those clowns out but but you know I just
say that because I know a lot of people
I'm not saying that to demean those guys
they threw some guys out but with that
what's not what makes me upset is I know
that so many other people come out to
the show they get a babysitter they
drive you know we had people drive three
four seven hours to get to the to
Charlotte this weekend and I was so
excited and then you get some some
clowns that come out and they're just
selfish they think it's all about them
and they're just ruining the evening
because they don't know how to be adults
and it just and it hurts me because it
makes it so I'm unable to you know drop
that hitter out there I'm able I'm
unable to you know do that just skeet
that word out into the out into the
crowd and create a good a good spider's
web of joy but I'm happy to be back a
friend of mine gave me a pin somebody uh
came to the show and gave me a pin one
of the curious crew that comes out to
see my shows and the pin was in memory
of his friend Alex that had passed away
and so I just wanted to say thank you
for that and we'll keep it here in
studio
another thing we got in a studio I got
an autographed baseball
I got an autographed baseball and a
baseball I mean I know you've seen it
before it's like a little white ball it
looks like a big it looks like a big
kind of nut or something off of a goat
if they had a big big goat that had hard
hard nuts that's what a baseball looks
like and and it's autographed by Noah
syndergaard from
the New York Mets and I saw my first
game ever was a Mets game years and
years ago and uh and um and I'm a fan of
Noah and he's and he's a supporter of
mine and so he gave me this autographed
ball and a friend of mine copped that
for me in and saw him at an autograph
session the other day and he wasn't
signing any balls but he signed one for
us here at this past weekend and so
we're very appreciative of that and it's
nice we're gonna have in a studio we're
getting some of the studio kind of put
together in a new atmosphere nothing
crazy but but uh but it's gonna be new
what's going on Charlotte I had a good
time I had a good time you know I went
out there I went over to Mertz they got
Mertz and they got soul food at Mertz
and I don't know if you never had so
food but they call it that because when
you put it in your body your [ __ ]
soul shows up to meet it I mean soul
food is just do you might not even think
you have a spirit and you put a tape I
mean this these yams were so candied
brother they were they were LGTBQ
[Music]
you know they were Don't Ask Don't Tell
yams these things were sweet I mean I
had yams they had a I had a catfish
filet man you could taste the lake you
could taste I mean it's it tasted like I
was eating a stack of beautiful
postcards you could taste the people
camping in the distance and making
coffee in the morning you could taste
the you know a family picnic and by the
edge of the stream that's how damn good
this catfish was you could taste the
mint the memories that were inside of
this catfishes head in its brain in its
soul and that's how good that catfish
was that catfish filet well I put it in
my mouth and that mother I swam right
down my gullet and that's soul food food
that meets your soul food that when it
goes in your body your soul your soul
says oh well what is this
this was made with love and care and
affection this wasn't made by some you
know you gotta beat it out of a box and
they got a prize at the bottom of it or
something you know back in the day they
used to have you know cereal or
macaronis and in the end of the at the
bottom of the box that have a little
trinket in there you know a little you
know a rape whistle or something like a
little whoa
you know one time it had a it was a um
it was a piece of uh like a peppermint
stick and it was just loose in the box
[ __ ] I actually that might have just
been somebody just spit a damn mint into
the cereal but you know they had a
different thing when I was young they
had a little item in there and you'd
reach your hand dude I remember when the
cereal when you got that cereal the
frosted flake when you get the frosted
flake and they got they used to have a
toy in the bottom they would put a toy
in the bottom a little you know a little
seat you know a rape whistle or a little
you know a picture of a monkey kind of
holding its nuts or a little statue of
um you know Benedict downs I don't know
and they put it in the bottom and you
had a slide your hand you had to you die
meaning you had to have precision and
get your hand right down the side of
that box all the way to the bottom and
then you had to make a perfect right
90-degree turn with your hand and feel
up under the side of the cereal take you
nine minutes brush somebody came up when
you you couldn't get your arm out fast
this was a slow vibe because you
couldn't spill the cereal out of the bag
it might you do know but you ain't
spilling cereal where I'm from because
if a flake hits there some of these
tongues gonna Kent is gonna meet it
halfway to the ground
and you get that and you reach your hand
out under there and you get that prize
and you would pull it out and it would
be a tattoo or something's you know
somebody says give blood on it or it
would be a UH a neck tattoo or something
you could lick it and put it on your
neck says you know something save these
hoes or you know something fun you know
or like a little locket around it would
have like a little locket with a picture
of like an old man or something in it
that you didn't know and you could wear
that but they had different prizes in
the cereal box and man it was I mean it
was fun to have back in the day that's
one thing I really really miss you know
I miss a lot of back in the day man I
miss being young I miss you know I'm
still happy that I'm alive though you
know that's the thing it's like I'm
happy to be able to have memories you
know memories are pretty are pretty cool
aren't they aren't they pretty cool do
you think memories are pretty cool
because you know a memory it's like your
brain is saying oh you know what bro
i'ma hold on it is for us daddy and
that's pretty cool you know because that
you know it's nice to know that your
brain that there's something inside of
you that's working for you sometimes
because oftentimes our brains can work
against us you know or not have some of
our best interests at hand and that's
the and that is the definition of the
dark arts right there you know we've
talked about it over the years and
that's the definition of the dark arts
is when your brain is making choices and
you're doing things you're doing
activities where you don't have your
best interests at hand
oh what else man oh I got some dates for
you some surprise dates I am coming to
Addison Improv Addison Texas one night
only December 6 December 7th and 8th
I'll be at comedy off Broadway in
Lexington Kentucky one of my good
friends from growing up my buddy Chad
lives there and I'm excited to get to
see him and he just moved there this
year and enough I feel like that's a
blessing because I didn't know when I
was gonna get to see him and then this
comes through the email and said that's
where I'm going you know you don't know
what's gonna come your way you don't
know what's gonna you know show up in
your world that is gonna that's gonna
make your soul light up you don't know
you don't know and that's why if the day
starts off bad if the week is then you
got to reintroduce yourself because if
you sit around waiting for the week to
you know oh well this month is free and
week you don't care about me it doesn't
yeah
you know I got gum in my hair oh well
then then there you go
but if you reintroduce yourself and get
you and meet it halfway you know if you
make yourself available for change for a
new opportunity in this week it's
Tuesday Monday and Tuesday were little
rocky whatever Wednesday let's not let's
let's reignite this you know
let me show let's treat each other
differently ask that of the week ask
that of the world you know if mother
nature's just giving you ah you know
that um she just giving you the dry milk
suds or you know the dry milk flakes you
gotta make ask her on Wednesday say hey
boo let me catch a hit off that tit I
need that fresh hitter cuz you know
Monday and Tuesday you've been giving me
this half way big no doesn't you know
mix the milk up in the cup this
confectioner's dust or whatever this are
let's check on cocaina you know you give
me this milk dust I gotta bring my own
water we're not may you know on
Wednesday if you need more ask for more
out of the world
reintroduce yourself say hey we started
off Rocky I noticed she was giving me
the bad you know that let say powder how
about uh putting that tit in daddy's
mouth for a day or two let's reintroduce
ourselves to one another you know you
make the milk and I'll do the lip work
we just got us sometimes reintroduce
ourselves because I get like that you
know and I say this I'm not preaching
I'm just reminding myself that you know
if things get rough too to just
recalibrate you know because you don't
know man you just don't know because if
you're in a good mood then you should in
the world can meet then then then good
things can happen to you you know what I
realize him and being alive nothing
great ever happened to me when I was at
the rock bar you know when I was in
total negativity but when I'm in the
middle man something really great can
happen so just get yourself to the
middle if you're struggling even get
yourself to the middle just get yourself
to the middle and see what shows up see
what lights your soul up because
something will land there's there you
know your soul wants to be alive and
there's good out there and things want
to happen and things that are good want
to happen to you they're waiting for you
they were they milling around in the
distance you know I'm singing if you if
you could see man if you had ultra you
know super vision circle you know
knowledge power visuals then you would
see in the distance maybe they got that
you know that five thousand dollar
lottery ticket hanging out in the
distance smoking a cigarette or maybe
they got uh you know that home loan
mortgage you want to get the deal and
they want the deal on this maybe that
thing sitting on the curb with a dip in
its mouth waiting for you you know you
want to meet the love of your life
maybe that matches your that male [ __ ]
is in a distance and a tent and they in
their hot box in that tents smoking you
know that chief chief that puffs out
that dope dope that greenie green that
leafy leaf bro that brain kale bro dope
marijuana's and they're just waiting for
you to get into a middle ground they
they they can't come into your world
because you got too much negativity well
just lighten up lighten your load
lighten your load and let your soul show
up because there's a lot of soul food
out there for you I got some in
Charlotte man so many nice people came
out I can't
look we had people come out a man Justin
came out brought me a card him and his
wife it was I think their say he was uh
you know um he and his wife was their
anniversary was his birthday he brought
me a birthday card a gentleman brought
me some coffee some nice coffee from New
Orleans a nice home gift it was just
beautiful a lot of beautiful people came
out and I'm just super grateful I can't
even tell you Oh
so we went and did the single mom we did
a single mom to single moms my girls
Heather and Erica and these ladies was
illegitimate okay if you wanna if you
want fresh breath why don't you have a
couple of these legit ament's because
your breath been smelling like you ain't
about nothing like you ain't getting
your work done well guess what what you
need is legit immense put a couple of
these [ __ ] in your mouth and next
thing you know things you're saying
making sense you're shown up with a
value flying out of your face
would that be a funny commercial legit
immense tired of talking [ __ ] get some
legitimates men I'm in a weird mood
today I think honestly I'm delirious I
don't think I am damn Eddie Murphy in
right now so the single mom that came
out was Heather and she brought her
friend Erica and we went bowling and I'm
not gonna say that they won but they did
and my feature came out this guy Ari
manis and so a lot of guys remember Ari
he came into the podcast early for this
past weekend like a year ago and helped
produce some episodes and Kim won as a
kind of a sidekick for I think three
episodes and a lot of listeners gave him
a hard time but um and so we didn't have
him on anymore but he he came out and we
just went had a good time man we had fun
and both of those ladies they have one
of them has two daughters and one of
them has one daughter I think 13 like
nine or and 22
I'm believer their children's age and it
was nice man they were beautiful girls I
mean Heather you know they were cool
because they showed up home not I mean
they showed up looking like they were
you know really fresh looking you know
like a couple little boo see it kind of
plucked him out of a you know out of a
great patch or something a couple of
beautiful grapes and they showed up and
then next thing you know we had him take
their shoes off and we're playing we're
bowling and everybody it was just a good
sport then we laughed we had a good time
and and I'm so grateful to the patreon
supporters and everything to make that
kind of experience possible and you
could tell that they they were they look
just love being moms and they you know
Heather you know she had a very
beautiful she was like a very they're
both beautiful young ladies and they had
a very Heather has a you know a lot of
really great motherly instincts and and
she was our mother and her friend was
Erica and Erica's kind of the one that
always gets him into trouble apparently
they're like Tom and Jerry kana and and
they're all and and we had fun man and
Heather you can just tell that she just
has a you know God just put like a read
you know some real special gifts in her
and she's you know she's a mom and so it
was just nice it was nice to take her
out and it was nice for her to come and
join us and Erica she's just like a DJ
you know she just she does she's like if
you have chilli she's the spice you know
she's that banana pepper you feel me
she's spicing things up but we but they
were both beautiful ladies and we had a
lot of fun and so thank you to patreon
for making that happen and we'll put a
little bit of that date out in the next
the single moms night out we'll put that
out in the next week or two we also did
a hidden-camera game show in the hotel
room they had a cleaning lady that works
at the hotel and I didn't think it was
gonna happen you know the day it started
off strange on on on Saturday I'd had a
long night Friday night of the shows and
people coming out and then one guy was
high on cocaine and wouldn't stop
talking to me at the end of the show and
had I mean look if you're gonna do
cocaine here's what I'm saying and you
this is coming from a former man that DC
did cocaine brush your teeth okay
through a couple little Ajith immense in
your mouth cuz some of y'all be getting
all coked up and dried out and your
mouth smell like you've been hiding low
doodoos behind you uh behind your molars
like they got a little doodoo crouchers
trying to pop out behind your tongue and
stuff brush your teeth if you're gonna
do cocaine get a little travel-size um
toothpaste and one of those little half
tooth brushes they give you at a hampton
inn go to the front desk of a hampton
inn take your [ __ ] take your bad
breath down at the front desk hit the
bell wait for the night manager to come
up okay oh hey night manager Daniel
whatever your name is
on
cocaine my breath stinks they'll give
you one of those little bitty
toothbrushes it's a half way hitter then
keep it in your pocket if you're gonna
do cocaine just because you're having
fun partying you know just because you
running around with a snout full of the
Devils up up doesn't mean everybody else
gotta be playing hide and go smell with
you Duke ever ever think about do do
think about your breath
now think about them together that's
what you're doing
so take proper care of yourself if
you're gonna do cocaine Gang Gang sorry
you don't have to go off on those on
those little tangents but man I had such
a great time I had a great time I know I
come back to that kind of as my default
but it was just special man people came
out and man I'll tell you this I had
some of my best shows this weekend that
I've had and I think a lot of it is just
the joy that's in the room and people
are excited yeah and it's just nice man
people you know you know people giving
hugs and it's feeling good and the
excitement in the air and to know that
the people that are watching the podcast
that some of the money's going towards
taking out single moms you know we are
the the hotel the cleaning lady man we
helped her cop an extra hundred and
forty dollars you know man as she was
feeling great and it was just you know
it's not a bunch but it's a little you
know and then I felt great after hanging
out the single moms because it made me
think about you know my mom you know
I've said it before my mom nope you know
a lot of people didn't take my mom out
when I was growing up you know and that
always kind of made you know and I
didn't realize it realize it as a kid
but it means something when you go over
there to pick a woman up if she has a
kid that you behave accordingly you know
because the kid
seeing that and my mother always had to
work and I wish that somebody would have
taken her out sometimes and I'm not
saying that these women are like that
that Heather and Erica were like that
but it's just nice we you know it's nice
to be a part of it because then it makes
me feel good it makes me feel like if
there's a hole inside of me you know
that still carries this emptiness around
that you know that I didn't see a man
take care of my mother or do something
nice for her that I can help fill that
own hole in myself by being a part of a
fun night with with uh with some ladies
that I don't know that have children you
know knowing that their kid is at home
but their kid is having fun because
somebody's just out doing something fun
with their mom and it's all on the up
and up and I'm also sick of the world
out there and the media and the news
making it seem like every man is bad or
we're dirty
it's the were the last thing in the
world I'm so sick of this people who get
off on just ruining making it seem like
all men are evil or ruining or ruining
the world are you out of your mind
men have ruined America or this shut it
down okay all men and women are we're
just we're Paul we're chess pieces of
mother nature mother nature's the one
moving us around you know we're done the
best
could overtime you know I'm just sick of
that a lot of this been a I believe that
more people way more people are good
than bad and there's a lot of great
people out there and a lot of them are
men and a lot of them are women and I'm
not gonna sit around and just let that
be okay that every man just gets
chastised for being a man it ain't
[ __ ] you think it's super easy being
a man okay it ain't easy so just shut
that down but anyway I'm gonna get out
of the negativity a couple of updates
the King in the sting podcast is
currently on hold we're gonna make it
happen Brendan Schaub has some stuff
he's he has some other work
opportunities and I'm happy for him you
know I'm so grateful to him and Bryan
Callen and their fighter in the kid
podcast and they've helped me you know
get into podcasting and just been so
supportive I'm really really grateful to
them we are still making it's still
gonna roll out it's just gonna roll out
a little bit slower but I want to thank
the artist submissions that have come in
and we're super grateful we're super
grateful man and it's still going to
happen
we have Sebastian Maniscalco in studio
this week so I'm so excited that that's
gonna be on if you haven't seen this man
he just see I mean he did four shows at
Madison Square Gardens okay and that's
the biggest garden next to what else
Garden of Eden mr. McGregor's garden and
sound garden so unbelievable Kabhi verse
Conor that was the jam that was the jam
man I think it was everything it was
cracked up to be
and a look at the N bro it got Russian
it got Russian people jumping in it um
into the octagon people jumping out of
the octagon here's the thing it's like
you want diversity in America you want
to welcome other cultures wolf [ __ ] got
Russian
so what you can't just welcome the parts
of other cultures you want your like
would be you know these nutcases I give
to be accepting of every single thing of
every
okay well then don't complain when [ __ ]
gets Russian people jumping in and out
people karate kick and doing tiger
attacks that's what happened and I think
the UFC man is quickly headed towards
tag matches could you imagine tag team
could you imagine
also if you don't follow Derek Lewis on
Instagram I think it's like the Beast
UFC or something that guys have one of
America's new favorite human beings he
tells it like it is and uh and I just
really enjoyed that what else what else
we got that's what we got but yeah I
loved being an arm I love being in
Charlotte I love being in North Carolina
a lot of people Mecklenburg County
representing came out people came in
from Raleigh again that had already seen
me eight weeks ago when they came back
you know people driving in South
Carolina I couples text me and email me
is their first comedy show that they'd
ever even seen you know I got an email
just a few minutes ago I'll read it to
you right now hey there just wanted to
let you know if for some random random
reason you read this email amongst a
thousands of emails you get I wanted you
to know that ever since my husband
passed away he was in the military
several months ago you have kept me
laughing and put a smile on my face
basically I just want to say thank you
for being you and please don't stop
making people laugh
lots of love Jessica that just came in
this evening but uh but man I just felt
the love and it keeps me excited you
know I think is we're gonna do some big
things as a group and we're just getting
started
but I had a blast this weekend so thanks
for making people that came out in
Charlotte thanks for making me a part of
your life because it it means a lot man
and I Anna and I thought about being at
home I miss being a kid I think with
Halloween coming up I think about that a
lot you know I was thinking one time me
and my brother we had all our candy Brun
them sacks was full you know him and
when your stack gets full the can
sack the items that are in it some of
them become dangers and I'm talking
about suckers because a sucker to me
it's a [ __ ] bank it's a bank candy a
sucker is if you if you don't know what
a sucker is it's like a piece of
sweetener at the end of a little white
stick and you suck on it and when you're
done you just have the stick in your
mouth is kind of I mean honestly it's a
little perverse but a human of that kind
of stuff then you into that kind of
stuff and if you if you see a boy that
eats too many suckers and then the
sticks get bigger and bigger and bigger
the next thing you know your boys in a
you know he might be into some wild
stuff he might be in a homoeroticism so
you never know it's kind of a gateway
it's kind of you know you know the
suckers at the bank can be a gateway
drug to a homosexuality and which is
fine so what I'm saying is this a sucker
though those sucker sticks late at night
in in a Halloween candy sack can poke
through the bag and that's dangerous
because you risk losing all your candy
and I remember one night me and my
brother at the end of the night we were
furious you know we were one of us was
raggedy and because my dad screwed up
and got the wrong costume frickin
unbelievable
one of us was Raggedy Ann and one of us
basically my brother he had glued a
bunch of [ __ ] laundry to his shirt I
don't know what he was doing an idiot so
but we're out there we had our sacks of
candy and we are you know at the end of
the night you're sweaty you're angry
that this was one time my mom had to
work and my dad and I had had to take us
trick-or-treating and we got lost bro
and we ended up in kind of like a
sketchy neighborhood and we almost got
[ __ ] up a couple times some of the
kids over there didn't even know it was
Halloween brah
so they don't know what we're talking
about trick-or-treat they thought one
person it was a um it was a black
person's house honestly and they I guess
they had a dude there his name was trick
we're like trick-or-treat and they're
like hold on let me get him and then
this dude showed up man and he seemed
like a nice guy but anyway but that was
a did you know it was back in the day
but uh but I just missed it man you know
and my brother and I would fight with
those candy sash you get violent at the
end of the night and then when your
candy sack broke it was nighttime so now
you're feeling all on the street in the
dark trying to know what's a candy and
what's a little stick or a leaf you know
we're a dirty um something they have a
dirty barrette sout in the yard and out
on the street and you don't know you're
trying to shovel all this [ __ ] back in
your sack and you don't know what's
candy and what's a you know a little
chunk of sweetener or a little sugar
chunk or what's just anything what's a
damn you know a little mouse skull
sometime they might have a mouse that
died and this skull is still out there
you know just just looking around and in
in the end of the world and you put all
that [ __ ] cuz you in a hurry now you got
to get home
my dad's yelling you know mr.
trick-or-treat trying to sell us a
[ __ ] lawnmower or something and we
got one Lee you know we got limited time
we got to get home see you shoveling all
the [ __ ] you've been fighting that
sucker rip through your candy sack that
suck a stick and now you got to get home
so you shovel anything you can off the
ground real fast bunch of rocks and [ __ ]
you get home you got like eight pieces
of candy you got a um you know you got
one of those little wah you got maybe
like a lighter you know you got a um
somebody make you know you might have
like a dirty Christmas ornament because
somebody was riding down the street one
time with their ornaments in the car and
they got in a domestic dispute and
[ __ ] threw them all out and you got
one of those you got a bunch of rocks
you got some gum but it's not new gum
it's like old gum that somebody had just
spit out their window or something
and it's you know it's hard now but you
also so you just get home with who knows
what
the times we had some crazy people in
our neighborhood man dude I remember
this one kid growing up this boy named
Morgan bro
is something people call him damp Morgan
and damp Morgan was I mean he had sweat
I guess it was sweat coming out of him
or something you know like Mother Nature
had kind of like my grab before he was
born he'd kind of you know his mother
had switched him around and in her womb
a little bit before she let him out in
the world and he had extra kind of
glistening on him all the time extra
sweat you know and Morgan was a good
wrestler bra damp Morgan because you
couldn't wrestle him he slide out
anything he slide out of it
you know you put he could barely you
know you he sits out on a chair he ended
up on the floor he couldn't tackle him
he could nothing would hold him you know
yeah him as a sleepover he starting the
bed he wake up on the floor he's fall
asleep upstairs wake up downstairs he
just has slippery's just you know he was
slick you know he was a slick boy and I
think mother nature just had kind of you
know it's like he had his own he's like
he was still just stating a little bit
he wasn't fully developed you ever go to
the car wash and you get all the
different settings in that last setting
sometimes you don't know when it's done
when your car is dry or it might still
be slick but you got to go and you go
off and you riding around with you know
soapy everything and slicked up and that
was like Morgan
he was always slick you pat him on the
back of your hand would slide right off
of them and here we are and damp Morgan
we go trick-or-treating with us and
people always gave him extra candy
because he looked a little wet and
there's something that happens to you
when you see somebody and they kind of
glistening a little bit it makes you
want to show up for him it makes you
want to show up for them a little more
and then after a while they put cinnamon
on him or they put a little bit of
powder or something on him to kind of so
we could get a little more grip you know
I remember in fourth grade they put
powder on his back every day so if he
sat down or something could hold you
know he could hold the line and not Lou
you know just end up on the ground and
he was just about the damn slickest kid
I wonder what ever happened to him I
know he dried up and eventually went on
the you know to college but I got to
check in with some of his family because
he was just a unique bird you know he
was I think his nerves were a little yet
his nerves were just frenetic and he was
a little bit leaky but mother nature
does that and he would come
trick-or-treating with us and he got all
the candy brother when you have [ __ ]
down Morgan with you out there people
give you everything people give you
money bro hugs prayers amulets all type
of things amulets you know pictures of
[ __ ] die you know people would draw a
picture of a diamond or something give
it to you because if they didn't have a
real diamond or anything to give you
just give you [ __ ] cheap artwork of
nice [ __ ] though so different time man
Mother Nature has different plans for us
sometimes and she made something special
out of him what else is going on I'll
tell you this in Charlotte these people
came out in support and I'm happy they
did Charlotte counseling and wellness if
you're looking to find a therapist and
it can be difficult it doesn't have to
be at Charlotte counseling and wellness
our counselors have dedicated their
lives to help you to go from stuck to
thriving and to become the person you
have always imagined available for
in-person counseling and therapy in
Charlotte go to WWll counseling and
wellness comm slash Theo to get started
today
that's WWll counseling and
wellness.com slash Theo and the owner of
that business John came out to the shows
in Charlotte and John it was nice to
meet you it was nice to put a face with
the Wellness thank you very much
another I add I'm gonna tell you about
Owen coming to Buffalo I'll come to
Buffalo in a few weeks are you guys
coming out or not because I don't think
the tickets have been selling and that's
November 1st through 3rd Buffalo New
York we just added a second show in Salt
Lake City November 9th and 10th it's
gonna be on I think Sunday or Thursday
that's it and we added a comedy loft
show in DC that Sunday night as well oh
this is interesting
so Skillshare there are a company we do
ads for and we're grateful to them but I
have all have the most popular classes
that our listeners have chosen on their
site so I'm going to go through those in
just a second Skillshare is an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more and more you can take classes
in social media marketing data science
mobile photography or creative writing
you name it they got it just you can get
two months of Skillshare for just 99
cents that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access unlimited
access this is the pornhub of making
yourself better Skillshare comm slash
Theo again go to Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo to start your two months now
that Skillshare comm slash Theo here are
the top ten classes this past weekend
listeners have signed up for
face book ads for e-commerce the
complete guide that's a good one trap
music production drums bass lines and
melodies hell yeah and we all get some
of them trap beats and trapeze send them
to Daddy we'll see if we can't throw
some of them into the end of the program
that just blew my mind though to think
that the people that are coming out that
a listener also learning how to make
trap music presentation essentials
Lebanese learning Lebanese unbelievable
sketch for beginners and designing your
own app so app designing mixing music
with young guru making Android apps and
get it made get it sold the basics of
sourcing and sales for entrepreneurs my
man it makes me feel good to know that
our listeners are thinking about just
new lessons to learn to better
themselves dude it I believe that we are
in a huge time right now of bettering
ourselves it is you know we have too
much knowledge down to not be trying to
operate at a higher potential or to meet
our potential halfway but you gotta meet
it halfway you owe it to yourself I
think you do I don't get appreciating
I'm hungry when I get hungry I get kind
of an in desperation I'm also kind of
exhausted so oh but you know I'm happy
to be alive and um you know I just
decided I'm gonna go home for Halloween
I get to see my nephews man that's gonna
boost me up I just think about those
boys smiling and laugh and even if
they're [ __ ] to me half the time
when I see them they're just kids kids
can do that you know but I'm excited to
see them and just just feel some of the
joy that life has to offer and so a lot
of that joy comes from other people and
interacting with others let's get to
some questions man we had a lot of great
questions that came in
here we go we had a response question
that came in a couple weeks ago we had a
certified welder Alvarez who refused to
clean up [ __ ] or do do you know and I
should have said doodoo I'm sorry but we
had a call that came in for him that was
a suggestion here we go I do I'm calling
a for Alvarez they're called
recently man I think you did the right
thing by not picking up this [ __ ] from
that toilet I'm a [ __ ] certified
welder - in the [ __ ] if I stick my hand
in a [ __ ] toilet you and that's true
man I'll tell you this if somebody I
mean that's bobbing for a used apples
you know what I'm saying that's bobbing
for already digested apples if
somebody's asking you to reach in at all
it and get a UH you know to get a doodoo
out I mean that kind of stuff you know I
mean I look I look huh you're talking to
a guy he used to bury somebody's doodoos
you know and my friend rest in peace
Mario but I used to bury his Doo doos
when we were young and people know about
this you know I don't keep this kind of
stuff in my in a closet you know in the
stool in the stool closet but you know
to do used to in order to let me hang
out with him he made me bury his Doo
doos in the yard and he was Italian he
was like 2,000 per tenant percent
Italian you know he'd stand there and
make hand gestures while I was burying
them and and so yeah you know I you know
this kind of situation I guess has a
special place in my heart because I've
had experience around you know Opie
Dedes but uh but anyway let's take this
suggestion here we go
know your self-worth yeah [ __ ]
maintenance man with certifications and
an AC vaca man there's work for you
anywhere and that big ass state of
California does work anywhere man I'm
110 percent behind you to your decision
you stood up for what the drive you know
yourself worse and you know they you
ain't worth picking up [ __ ] from a
toilet tell that man to go [ __ ] stuff
to go pick up that [ __ ] [ __ ] himself
it's probably him that did
all right will feel great podcast man
love listening listening to it gets me
through the day
pay up player yeah hang gang gang gang
daddy and looking out and I respect that
in you know and and look that's a
co-worker that's a cohort right there
that knows your Worth and hearing you
stand up for you in a self worth man and
uh and you know what he just convinced
me of yeah he's right you got to stand
up for your own self-worth you know you
really really do and especially look if
somebody uh I'd rather have somebody do
do right into my hand and go get it out
of a toilet because then it's like it's
like you're not even it's like oh you
couldn't even you know it's like I'm not
even worth enough for you to just [ __ ]
in my hand I gotta go get it out the
toilet you know what I'm saying it's
like but yeah way to stand up for
yourself in and you know I guess I was a
you know I was like do you have another
job those are some of my thoughts but I
think this man is right you stand up for
yourself worth I've never met anybody
who stood up for their self-worth whose
life didn't continue to get better never
never do when you when you do the right
thing
your life gets better when you to even
if it's hardly you know you stay in that
line life gets better man and we're
gonna reach out to that guy and see how
things have been going with him
Alvarez but we appreciate a co-worker of
his somebody that you know has
experience in that field and to offer
him advice and suggestion there mana it
is mana self-worth it's not it's not
fair and that dude shouldn't it made me
bury his duties when I was growing up
because it made me feel all kind of
weird and then after that I'd be in the
bathroom when I was young because the
next you know I'm in elementary school
and I'm the dude milling around you know
listening to the toilets flush hoping to
make a new friend in the bathroom you
know I got everything all jumbled in me
but let's take some other calls man the
hotline as always is nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three
and let's get to some calls thank you so
much for using the hot line the hot line
is a place we can call if you're
struggling with something if you have
input about the show you know if you
were whatever smoking menthols whatever
whatever you're doing it was something
you want to share or input you have
you're welcome to give it their
questions you can ask you're welcome to
put them there and and what else
someone's gonna say oh we get a lot of
calls you know and sometimes people call
you know you li you want to be a and
we're trying it's like it's hard it's
really hard it's hard to go through them
all and it's hard to you know figure out
and get them on the show
it doesn't even we're not grateful that
you call if you do call and it didn't
get on and that's okay it just didn't
fit this time or we just couldn't do it
sometimes I'll have you know we get at
least 200 calls a week and some of those
are anywhere that from one to three
minutes so when you think about that say
that they're a minute say they're 90
seconds each that's 1,800 minutes of
phone calls I think I don't know I can't
even do math that good but uh we're
grateful but just understand if you can
all right let's hit let's hit this one
hey Theo with the Kylie from Oklahoma
hey Kylie from Oklahoma I don't know if
you guys won that shootout in Texas this
past weekend that Red River robbery but
if you did or didn't I hope it went okay
for you no matter what homewards you
said you had any thoughts about it about
your opinion on like affects is over you
know broadcasted or whatever and I
wanted to say the guy I do think is sure
I mean I'm young I'm I'm 18 so you know
I really have been involved with
technology really hands-on you know just
because of how young I am and there is
like I know people who literally have
made money like girls like friends who
have made money you know selling a new
photo of themselves like right so she's
saying is sex - is it too much sex with
technology and she's eight
tene calling in from oklahoma thank you
homeward and it's like a lot of what
guys focus on like that's like you think
the guy wants to you know have a
conversation with you but now he just
want some news so i don't know
just as a young person's perspective I
do think it's gotten way different than
how it used to be well and you probably
and you know I'm not judging I'm this
and this isn't darling judgment is in
the world but thank you for calling
thank you for calling yeah and it used
to be and you had to use your
imagination I mean I had to imagine a
tent
I remember we go out they had this tree
and somebody had chiseled some nice tits
into it you know we go out there bran
hopefully you go out there and hopefully
nobody else was out there and you could
pleasure yourself by it but I mean if
you went out there sometimes some dudes
out there somebody's parked in a truck
right by and you're like [ __ ] man
somebody's already using that thing and
that was something beautiful man I mean
somebody I don't know who had done it
you know Nostradamus Michelangelo
Geppetto I don't know but somebody had
come and chiseled some of the most
beautiful wooden tatata tatata Oh Papa
into this tree and man when you got out
there bro it didn't even look like they
were wood it looked like they were made
out of
today meat and it was just beautiful man
somebody had done it the nipples was
they painted these you know these robust
kind of hardy sort of Italian kind of
you know uh the south chicha de pavo you
know kind of just just little just I
mean if what didn't even look like
nipples it look like Justin you know
nervous little you know nervy little
hood ornaments on the each of
on the tip of each top a man you see and
you get out there by the tree and you'd
hope nobody else was out there so you
could you know enjoy a little bit of
quality time between yourself and the
dark arts that were flowing through your
brain brain veins brains and and you'd
be out there but sometimes you go out
there to already have a dude out there
you know or somebody out there you know
some a man would come out there sometime
and do a picnic and also you know some
of these romantic guys out there they
got a nice spread the cheese and
everything and they still enjoying their
own body looking at the you know that
tree but it was that was a different
time
but anyway what you're saying yeah
there's too much sex these days well I
can't believe I mean it's it to me it's
an epidemic and people say you're crazy
people can jerk off whenever they want
yeah they can that's fine but
pornography in America to me is an
epidemic when you had because we're
we're saying we're we have a desire
inside of us a magnet inside of us you
know it's like a that wants to get out
that wants to be sexual it's it's not
you know like I hate this thing like men
are so they're pervert the the main
reason we exist as men and women is
because we are magnetized towards each
other the magnet is in us
you can't denounce humanity I mean it's
like the magnet lives in us and so when
you should I forgot man and my brain is
a brain is so it's not even it's like
Kodak it's not even IBM or it's
definitely not Apple it's definitely not
Texas Instrument but what was I saying
yeah but so anyway so so that attraction
it's a of course but it's gonna it has
to defend itself against pornography
because because we're attracted we are
sexually that magnet is in US and so
porn is just the other it's just
somebody putting that other side of the
magnet it's taking it out of the woman
or the man or whatever you're into and
putting it into a screen and serving it
to you
piping hot 24 hours a day and it used to
be you know look it was different
I remember you get out in the yard
sometimes and you know people would be
wild you know I'll tell you even uh that
boy Morgan damn Morgan would get out
there he was so slick he put a little
you know he dig a little you know a
little pocket into the earth and just do
his deal you know and just literally
salt of the earth he literally just
planting his own seed out there man
nothing ever grew out of the ground
thank God because it'd be really awkward
to see a guy you know a baby out there
you know with roots but but yeah it was
just different and so there is too much
sex out there and I can't believe that
it's not more mandated that it's not
government mandated they'll let us you
know drugs are and this and that and and
I know it's like less government I don't
know if we are powerful enough as humans
to defeat it so what I'm sick of is why
do we keep allowing things to exist and
keep creating more things when we know
that they defeat the very core of us as
humans it's like someone saying hey
here's a bunch of fire oh it's gonna
burn all your skin and bones off but
yeah here's more of it so I don't know
if it's really like that but it just
obviously I have an angry spot it is too
much and it is yeah and it [ __ ] and then
it ruins this why I feel bad about it
too because then women you don't get the
men that you deserve you get men that
are used to seeing
like in you know I mean it's like some
of these porno videos the thing is it
starts off it's a woman hitchhiking
right or a damsel in distress or just a
lady maybe even just sitting by a by um
you know sitting by a river and then
within nine minutes they're doing you
know dirty sex or you know by our booty
sex or everything nine minutes so of
course yeah it's like if you meet a girl
a guy these days he has you know his
brain has been put under a dirty spell
by pornography to think that well within
you know 17 minutes somebody better have
you know it I better be in a dank
threesome and it's just really bad
training and I feel bad for women
because you bear the brunt of it in some
ways that you don't get men that you
know you're just you're getting a
weakened diluted uncertain form of men
sometimes not all the time
I'm not putting men down you know men
are great creatures but but the
pornography weakens the the level of
connection that we can bring to you and
it dirties it and I think that that's a
huge problem because it really it gnaws
away at
a lot of the vitamins and a lot of the
virility that exists in love it kind of
squeezes that stuff out of it porn does
it chokes up a lot of that stuff out of
out of the love that we bring to the
table sometimes so just be careful be
careful of the dark arts all right let's
get to some more calls that came in the
hotline as always as nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three
what else did I want to tell you guys
here we go hey uh my name is David I'm
50 [ __ ] 2 years old
what's up David boy 52 son you halfway
to 104 daddy so you got halfway killer
breath um word but listen to you for a
while I like the [ __ ] that you're doing
but here's the gig I was three-sport
Letterman in high school
good-looking guy and all the girls I
ever wanted grew up in a place that was
pretty much have it boom I grew up on
her in the beach of Lake Michigan ooh
that sounds nice one thing I've always
wished that I have done so far in my
life that I haven't done is spent a
summer in Michigan you know I have a
cousin his name is James venom and and
he's a really great man he's a family
man and and he spends his summers up
there his wife's from up there and I
always wished that I would be able to go
up there one day I will but our own word
26 years old got out of college moved
Chicago but a girl got married on
Catalina I was in California after I had
lived out there for a while oh yeah
that's a nice place out there and they
have Buffalo out there somebody brought
two Buffalo out there to like a
Christmas party or something and got
[ __ ] up or whatever and left him out
there and the Buffalo started doing sex
because that's Nature Boy and and they
made and now there's tons of Buffalo out
there on her on an island homeward went
back to Chicago land area friend of mine
pushed me off of a boat dock at my
wedding reception paralyzed 26 but in a
wheelchair for [ __ ] little over half
my life
Wow that took a wild turn man I'm sorry
to hear that man
yeah little over half your life you've
been in a wheelchair homeward I can't
get mad at the people [ __ ] crowd say
I can't do this can't do that
I look at [ __ ] people eat themselves
in the [ __ ] wheelchairs they're so
[ __ ] fat lazy that they [ __ ] eat
themselves into a wheelchair when I
would give [ __ ] anything to be able
to walk be able to do the [ __ ] that I
used to do I've also added it that
people nowadays expect so freakin much
from everybody else
people [ __ ] look to the government
people look to the rich people look to
the hard workers to say give me
something nothing [ __ ] is free in
this world
there you go nothing is free not even
the guarantee that you'll have you know
you see your limbs that you'll have
tomorrow that you'll have you know the
second half of the breath you're taking
right now nothing it's not guaranteed
you know and that's an interesting story
David I appreciate you sharing it with
us you know I really appreciate you
sharing it with us
and you're right man look I agree
there's a lot of handout culture out
there there's a lot of gimme culture
there's a lot of lazy times there's a
lot of people that have just you know
you know people sitting at home not
doing anything for years and then
finally they start advertising diseases
on television that you get from sitting
at home watching TV and suddenly
everybody thinks that they have one
there's a lot of like lack there's a lot
of lacking out there a lot of people
that don't have desire that you know I
think also it is there's a lot of side
effects of comfort in America like we
start like you get to a point where you
know you have some you know you have air
conditioning you have water you have
everybody's get you know
everybody has and if we get too
comfortable you know there's a lot of
that I mean I appreciate your point of
view yeah there's a lot of people and it
may seem wonderful yeah why where is the
desires that are inside of us why are
they so weakened these days
y-you know like when I think about the
fact that men used to go would go to war
and this when you think about what
people went through in Vietnam we
couldn't go through an hour of that
today
the average man there and they used to
draft that meant everybody had to go
except for rich people and handicapped
people everybody else had to go fight
and I don't mean all rich people you
know what I'm saying man them Dodgers
brah the Los Angeles Dodgers could you
imagine that
they show up and half the people at York
if half the people that work even in the
building more our studio is had to go
dude some of these guys have so much
asthma some of these way week at just
worms la has so many wormy people half
these dudes can't even digest a [ __ ]
banana without having to take a couple
of supplements
and they're gonna go fight they couldn't
do it but a lot of us couldn't do it
I know it's interesting I think you know
and I can only fathom what you know what
your life has been like and you know
probably a lot of anger I would imagine
builds up god man I really can't imagine
that to go from I mean you sounded angry
you know you sounded like a lot of this
makes you angry you know and I wish
there was a way you could find some more
peace for that you know I don't know I
don't I mean [ __ ] I get angry and I have
my you know most most most of my
faculties and I wasn't a 3 star athlete
I wasn't even a damn 1 star guy when I
worked at that pizza place I was maybe a
2 star bus but I felt about a 3 star bus
boy when I worked at this countless
Busboys restaurants I was a two-star
dishwasher mmm I was 4 star when it came
to stealing a bike out of my
neighborhood ride across town and get a
little bit of laughing you feel me but
man
wild story man it makes me kind of
doesn't I mean it makes me sad it makes
me you know I feel bad that that
happened to you I wish your friend
wouldn't have done that you know and he
didn't know somebody pushed some kid off
on our high score he's on a boat and his
own brother pushed him off the front of
the boat and you could hear the [ __ ] the
propeller hit him as the boat went over
him and thank God it just cut his leg or
something
this boy Necati he didn't have a neck
and he's still uh but then that way had
nothing to do with him he didn't have a
neck before they pushed him in but uh
but yeah I can imagine that you see like
man that you have that desire you know
and you do and you see it lacking in
others but it's like how do we get that
back how do we reignite the men I know
we do we don't do it by beating them all
down and making them second-guess every
move that they make in the world you
know I do think it's it's good to bring
a lot of things to awareness you know
I'm glad there's some awareness about
sexual assault and that sort of thing
going on these days I'm glad that people
aren't thinking of women as second-class
citizens but I don't like us thinking of
men as as creeps and perverts and you
know denouncing even their own existence
that's not safe that's not a safe way to
do it but I appreciate your call man and
I appreciate your interest in and
support in this past weekend and you
look I mean I think that's a tough love
way to go about it but you know why are
people struggling why are people you
know how would what is wrong with men
today why are we struggling with some
stuff you know is it and I think mother
nature is gonna write the ship soon I
think about this a lot like you know all
this mental health and all these things
is this the way that we're supposed to
exist as humans or will mother nature
start to feel that what's going on and
something's going to occur that's gonna
reignite the the legs and the arms and
the and reconnect the spines inside of
all of us men and not just you my
brother but but yeah it's like how do we
but in the meantime we have to work with
where we are and I you know I does that
man that's sitting there on his couch
for that lady that's doing you know
having 60 snickerdoodles in the
afternoon and nine episodes of Judge
Judy does she want to be doing that
it's sad when it's a hand me out people
yeah I do it's like how you got to
ignite people's families or how do you
get that seed in them to want to succeed
I don't know I don't know I wish I knew
more so I knew what the effects were you
know I even thinking about it and doing
some stuff like we you know we want to
start this you know like we did this
game show the other day where we were
helping a cleaning lady get some extra
cash and I thought for my second well
what if you know what if they did what
if somebody uses money and they go do
something bad
I can do about that part all I can do is
just the front part try to help see what
they do you know you know I don't know
it's interesting man thank you for
calling thank you for help me thinking
about it man and I wish you know I wish
I had a way to lift some of that anger
off of you but I can't I can't tell you
that I wouldn't be the same way man
you know I mean I'm judgmental as it is
and and I get angry too
so but I wish you didn't feel that anger
you know I wish you felt you know I wish
you felt better
I mean look me you're still a three star
athlete to me dude [ __ ] I was a 2 star
busboy I was I was a three star busboy
uh onward let's take another call hey
Theo my name is Patricio I'm from
Minneapolis obviously you're very
creative individual what did you think
that or not you know you got that wit
wit oh thanks man I appreciate it when I
was young you know I didn't have a way
to really defend myself or anything and
so I had to use words you know words
were they were free and
no I think every member it was one thing
like other people had other stuff like
things or you know fail you know things
they have family or things or you know
you know popcorn or stuff like that or
breakfast at the house with the you know
they had things that I wanted but I
didn't have those so I had to have
something that was free that I could use
and so I guess my brain told chose words
all word funny guy thanks brah I
appreciate it
just wondering how like you keep
creative juices flowing or get your
inspiration from on a day to day basis
you know and if you're ever feeling you
know creatively dry um yeah so that's my
question thank you so much that's a good
question and I have actually I have a
lot of definitely suffered from it this
summer feeling kind of warped and just
feeling tired you know the feeling tired
feeling warped feeling exhausted of
creativity and so thinking of ways to
kind of replenish that you know I
noticed if I stay away from like you
know people not battle you know smoke
Sesay cigarettes you know sometimes and
that's them little smile
you know them small that little devils
DX and um and if I don't smoke a lot of
those and I find my creativity is better
if I stay active I find that my
creativity is better and but yeah I do
feel dry a lot of times and the hard
part is I just feel taught my brain
feels tired like it's just been run a
lot like it needs a tune-up it's like
it's hard to get in touch sometimes um
with my feelings because I've just been
busy it's hard for my feelings to get
some rest so I'm gonna find some new
ways to do that coming up and I think as
things get more efficient then I'll be
able to do that as well but thanks for
you guys as patients as listeners you
know I fear a lot of times that I'm
gonna lose listeners um you know or lose
our group that we've created so I guess
some of it is fear too you know I start
to get scared and then it's hard to be
creative when you're in
Saphir sometimes which is one thing I
miss about being a child when you were a
child
I mean creativity saved you so many
times even if you were scared you know
like you could be in a bad situation but
you could think that you know you could
take yourself out of it with your
imagination let's take another call
onward hi do
it's Molly Martin from New Albany
Indiana hey Molly thank you for calling
from Indiana Spanish for Indian oh we're
in Nashville few weeks ago but I was
just reviewing today episode from Monday
and we were talking about bonus therapy
at first of all thank you for being so
open about going to therapy I think
there's a lot of stigma around that
especially for men and I think it's
really awesome that you talk about it
that way and maybe and some of your
listeners are so more comfortable going
to therapy because of your example and
but my question is you said that you
have q therapists and I'm super curious
why you have two therapists like is one
therapist for certain things and the
other for other things or uh no I'm just
like super curious what that's all about
thank you Miss Martin for calling in
that's a good question I go to one
therapist it's just been just like a
therapist of mental health therapists
that I've gone to and then I go to one
for like kind of like emotional
addiction kind of stuff you know I
struggle with you know it's like a
center that's specifically for that sort
of thing and I've struggled with
being able to emotionally connect you
know with others so you know and so I
like to try and focus on that kind of
stuff
[Music]
you know because it
you know it's crazy that you can exist
and some of the best parts of life you
won't get them because you're not
calibrated correctly and I just you know
I want to get all the fields out of this
out of this deal you know I've done it
you know I've gotten to do you know like
I've gotten a lot of the you know I've
had gotten like a lot of the fun stuff
and done them you know now I searched
for the fields and other places you know
I've done steroids and uh you know I'm
you know my buddy you know and he was
homoerotic and we used to you know park
on the side of the interstate we were
both Busboys and I was a four-star
busboy son and we were you know he's one
of my best friends and he died he drove
into an embankment on pills out there
but he uh and we were just friends but
he we used to do steroids and go to the
gym you know I tried to you know let me
get big to feel good let me you know I
tried doing the cocaine and you know
meeting you know meet me strange women
off of the world and you know looking at
wild woman's butt holes and all of that
and doing that kind of deal in thinking
about the dirty dirty dirty dirty and so
I don't know I'm just still on this
search where I want to figure out what's
what's what's possibly inside of me and
what's you know I'm out here I'm [ __ ]
speed lankan inside of myself you know
and I know that uh you know I know that
I have a ability to to tell a story or
two or eight or to speak we all have
different abilities you know God gives
us different things or our higher power
gives us different things someone could
be a dancer someone could be a speaker
you know and I want to and and if I can
help communicate ways to emotionally
learn about oneself to others
yeah I just want to give my gift of
being able to communicate as much
ammunition as it can so you know that's
why I go to two therapist I guess cuz
I'm just curious about it you know it's
like I'm a coal miner and I'm [ __ ]
pickaxe in a way at the inside of me so
I guess that's some of it I don't know
that's a good question I'm a little bit
tired right now but let me take another
caller and thank you for calling young
lady and thanks for your interest what a
feel my name is Karim from Oklahoma I
was just watching this most recent
episode of this past weekend you got on
the subject of a blind guy for a blind
person and what their experience is like
yeah we were trying to have a blind
person on the show so we can learn more
about what that's like you know cuz
we're out here battle on the dark arts
and there the shoot their battle in the
dark so I'd love to know more about it
homeward and I'm sure it's different for
every blind person but I actually got to
sit and talk with a guy about this
subject who was blind I was hiking the
Appalachian Trail and I met him in
Damascus Virginia at a festival called
Trail days his name is quest and we are
dabbling in some dark arts getting into
some fungi oh you're on the mushrooms
you eat mushrooms of the blind dude hell
yeah boy that's like The Legend of Zelda
right here more and I asked him I was
like man what's it like getting into
these psychedelics as a blind person and
he told me that [ __ ] I'd love to know
what it's like even getting into a sack
of Doritos as a blind person I wonder if
that cheesy dust hit your tongue the
same way if you can't see it do you feel
like you just just tasting a damn
triangle of the Lord homework for him
blindness is not darkness he constantly
sees like these fields of color and
geometry and so it's already kind of
psychedelic as it is without any of that
external stimuli but I just thought that
was a kind of cool
kind of cool and I wanted to share my
experience with you anyways gang gang
much love from Oklahoma gang gang
love back at you that's that boomerang
gang gang bruh you threw it out at me
and I [ __ ] touched that thing and spun
around like a child
boomerang gang I'll tell you this man I
can't imagine me in line and on
mushrooms dude just out there
hitchhiking through the Lord's [ __ ]
like that come on
can you imagine while just hitting warp
zone after warp zone dude that's
fascinating a fascinating to be blind in
on mushrooms
wow that's brave dude I've done some
brave stuff you know but I've never done
anything like that I mean that is just
man do it on one time put my sometimes
if you pull your nuts up over your
wiener right I don't know why I'm such a
kid but it looks like a baby's head is
coming out of the middle of your body
and sometimes I would do that you know
and run in like a party room or
something show it everybody in everybody
would like you know have fun and cheers
and I can look it's a girl uh but I've
never been blonde I've never but I've
never been brave enough to eat mushrooms
and be blind at the same time so kudos
to you guys may you inquest dude out
there on a mission all right let's take
one more comon I'm gonna shut it down
and go home I love you guys
hit the hotline as always nine eighty
five six six four nine five zero three
I'm coming up I'll be in Appleton
Wisconsin Phoenix Buffalo Salt Lake City
Addison Texas Washington DC and
Lexington kin techie
yeah homeward hye-kyo my name is
Courtney from Seattle
my fiance and I are totally in love we
are each other's best friends everything
is awesome between em and I but the only
problem is we have very different sex
drive I have a very high sex drive okay
you got that and ready you got that and
ready in your in in your veggetti
homework and his is very low okay so he
got that bumper-to-bumper in his thumper
homework and my question for you is and
maybe some of the female callers could
answer it what do you do if you're a
woman and the person that you're with
has a low sex drive I love him you have
a child together
and I've worked really hard to you know
get back in shape and spice things up
and I've been doing a really good job on
my end and it's like he just doesn't
think about it it's not something that
is really important to him I don't want
to break up with handsome I love him to
pieces but I'm just every guy that I've
been with that's never been an issue so
I think so much okay and that's never
been an issue but those guys also that
was a previous time that was a time when
you were younger you know
now you've been with this manual of a
child together there's a lot more
experiences a lot has occurred you know
when you're younger you yeah I can't
compare the girl I was with when we was
16 out there you know words out there by
the riverside out there you know
filling each other's mouths of
wildflowers and doing you know doing you
know heavy oral and everything putting
sand in our mouths and you know licking
each other's crotch areas and everything
just what let feeling people just each
feeling each other unravel you know with
that gravel
that was different times you can't now
it's correct you told your it's
different there's a couple things you
can see if he's interested in other
people give him a get-out-of-jail-free
card
and you might think well that's crazy
but here here's my thoughts on some of
that is it crazy if sometimes it can
spark things up you know you get out
there if you've been having rye you know
you've been having rye for so long let
him get out there and catch a couple you
know a little hit of pumpernickel you
know let him catch a little bit of that
uh that Mazal ball or something
different it you know it's like maybe he
could use that maybe that and I know
that's a brave option but here's what
you're doing by that you're not saying
this something might sound crazy to some
women but I don't think it is we live in
a time where sex is like it's become in
a good way it's become more I think it's
become like I don't think it's about as
much like save your virginity for you
know like till marriage I don't think
it's as much that as much these days as
it is like well let's don't think about
sex is the big connector let's think of
it as important for sure but let's think
about emotionally what's keeping us
together let's think about understanding
you know because this set where we're a
little bit warped as a species right now
is sex I mean the girl called in earlier
about it so you got have you got to meet
the situation where we have to meet it
where we're at he might be shocked if
you said hey what if I you know get you
a little bit of uh you know buy you a
party starter one night you know it
doesn't mean you don't love him it
doesn't mean it unloved you you just
sometimes you got to put a little bit of
uh paprika and your sneaker you know if
you've been jogging on [ __ ] ah if you
just been jogging on ginger sometimes
your feet ain't feeling the spice and so
you gotta put a little paprika and a
sneaker and then suddenly you out there
you like
you know some of you out there you
freaking car Lulu you know Carl Louganis
bro you're running the 700 that's the
thing sometime you gotta get that
variety is the spice of life and so
maybe throw your throw you throw your
man a little spice hitter doesn't mean
you don't love him he doesn't love you
you might have to change it up you know
and then he'll come back and be like oh
wow
then then you're the new thing so that's
one option
another option is I mean I don't know if
it sounds like you guys are
communicating about it so there's not a
communication issue and I don't know
what another I mean that's one option
yeah I mean you could you could as well
you could offer to do that you could
offer and at first he might be like no
even though he wants to really talk
about it and consider it you know about
it you know experimenting with others
you know you could talk about maybe
doing something real naughty that you're
not used to doing or you know sneaking
another lady which I'll hire a woman
they have sex workers out there who are
comfortable women who run good
businesses who are clean and take care
of themselves and you know and they want
to help situations like this so you know
um I don't know that could be an option
and I'm and I could be totally wrong you
know I mean I don't know I struggle I'm
seeing two therapists so it's double
duty right now but uh but if you know
that he loves you then you guys should
be able to talk about any options and
sometimes
you know what though as a
oversexed as we are and is oversexed as
everything is these days it's just about
the love sometimes you know does it even
matter something where you get that kick
at sometimes it's about the love it's
about
you know sex is become so rampant it's
like anybody could do sex but to know
you love somebody or that somebody loves
you it's like that's the new sex through
somebody that'll hold my hand and you
know you know squeeze a go-gurt into my
mouth while we watching an episode of
Dateline
that's the new sex you know love is the
new sex I think sometimes sometimes and
I could have no idea one time I am
almost delirious but I love you guys man
I know that and uh and if and if things
is a little wonky then then they meet
the day halfway
you know renegotiate how your day is
going anything can change you know we
got to be malleable you know if
something you know it's okay sometime
you got a you got to be malleable but I
I'm gonna step out guys I appreciate it
thank you everybody in Charlotte that
came out we are still excited about the
King and the sting we are still we are
still it's still gonna happen it's just
the wheels are gonna move a little bit
slower but it's going to give us more
time to prepare it
but you guys be good man stay awake take
care of yourself
take care of someone else there's no
better way to take care of yourself than
by taking care of someone else if you
don't feel loved go love somebody then
they feel it and guess what BAM you'll
feel it too man cuz you just made it
inside of yourself thank you so much I'm
delirious I am out of here tiny sand who
again leading us out of here with that
back in black hitter
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
be good to yourself man and woman you
probably deserve it
[Music]